forests farmland and homes flooded to
make way for cambodia's largest dam the
lower cesan ii
human rights watch estimates nearly 5
000 people were displaced
sesame is one of them
i feel very nostalgic and sorry seeing
this
a submerged village is a loss of
identity and our ethnicity
no matter how angry i am at the
government i can only keep it in my
heart because i cannot do anything about
it the government did not pay any
attention to us
he and many other villagers mostly from
the punang minority group say they were
not properly consulted and were offered
inadequate
the compensation ground of our parents
and ancestors is submerged we've lost
our home our rice field our crops why
did this development have to make
villagers shed tears
strongland's family is one of 50 who've
refused to move to a new settlement
built for them by the government and the
chinese company that operates the dam
instead they've built their homes on
patches of land close to their old
village
others accepted compensation and moved
to the new site five years ago where
there's a health center and a school
but they say they're worse off than
before
tong samong says he moves between his
old village and the new one
this house i still live in but i come
and go i can't grow any crops on this
land because it's so saturated so i left
to find another plot near the old
communal land
fish stocks have reduced something
fisheries experts had warned would
happen if the dam that's built on a
major tributary of the mekong river went
ahead
a government spokesman told al jazeera
the country needs energy security and
the dam is beneficial to people in
cambodia adding that local authorities
will assist any community in need
villagers here say they're not against
development but don't expect to be the
only ones paying the price for it
this is the sacrifice we've had to make
if not for the dam we would not have to
give up anything the dam allows others
to prosper we are in tears while others
benefit
human rights watch says the government
should increase compensation payments
and provide more services and training
to affected communities
but many here doubt that message is
being heard
florence louis al jazeera